In the George R.R. Martin books that HBO's
Game of Thrones is based on, the character
of Beric Dondarrion has a relatively small
part to play.
But when you have an actor as talented as
Irish star Richard Dormer, you want to showcase
him as much as possible.
Here's a look at some of Dormer's previous
roles to help you remember just why Beric
from Game of Thrones looks so familiar.
Hurricane
Dormer got his start on the stage, appearing
in over two dozen plays.
In 2002, a one man play he wrote and starred
in resulted in Dormer's big break, with his
portrayal of controversial Irish snooker star
Alex Higgins in Hurricane garnering rave reviews
over its three-year run.
Higgins himself was a fan of the play, attending
several performances and striking up a friendship
with Dormer.
Following Higgins' battle with throat cancer
and subsequent death in 2010, Dormer revived
the play for a last hurrah at the Belfast
Opera House in order to give "a final farewell
to a true genius and a legend."
Hidden
In 2011, Richard Dormer landed a featured
role in the four-part BBC thriller/conspiracy
drama Hidden, starring Philip Glenister as
small-time solicitor Harry Venn.
When Venn is asked to help track down the
truth about a missing witness, he finds himself
well over his head in a deep conspiracy that
may have ties to his own dark past.
He enlists the help of Dormer's character
Frank Hanna, a resourceful ex-con who's out
of his depth, and finds himself in more than
one sticky situation along the way.
Whatever Venn is paying him, it's definitely
not enough.
Hunted
A year after his appearance in Hidden, Dormer
returned to television when he appeared in
two episodes of the Cinemax/BBC television
series Hunted, joining Game of Thrones alumni
Stephen Dillane and Indira Varma in the production.
Dormer played venture capitalist Lewis Conroy,
who is present during a murder committed by
his business partner, Jack Turner.
Conroy later attempts to track down the woman
who witnessed their crime in order to find
out exactly how much she knows.
Good Vibrations
In 2013, Dormer teamed up with yet another
Game of Thrones co-star — Liam Cunningham
— for a dramedy based on the life of Belfast
record-store owner Terri Hooley, founder of
the "Good Vibrations" record store.
Set during the height of the violent "Troubles"
in the 1970s, Good Vibrations finds Hooley
opening his Belfast shop on "the most bombed
half-mile in Europe."
After hearing some up-and-coming underground
punk bands, Hooley embraces the new art form,
inspiring to start his own record label.
Good Vibrations gained wide critical acclaim,
bringing Dormer a Best Actor nomination at
the Irish Film and Television Awards.
"It's showing you know, a sense of people
rising above and against something that's
ultimately dark."
'71
In 2014, Dormer starred in another film about
the Troubles when he appeared in the historical
thriller '71.
When a unit of the British Army is deployed
to Belfast, they find themselves stationed
in a dangerous neighborhood with Catholics
on one side and Protestants on the other.
Under attack from both sides, they're forced
to withdraw, accidentally leaving one soldier
behind.
Dormer plays a Catholic man who helps the
soldier, putting his daughter's life in grave
danger.
We're Doomed!
The Dad's Army Story
Created in 1968 by Jimmy Perry and David Croft,
the sitcom Dad's Army focused on a fictional
group of British Home Guard soldiers during
World War II.
The show became one of the U.K.'s most beloved
comedies, running for 80 episodes and spawning
two different movie adaptations.
In 2015, the BBC premiered a TV movie about
the making of the series called We're Doomed!
The Dad's Army Story, with Richard Dormer
playing the series' co-creator, David Croft.
11 Minutes
Also in 2015, Richard Dormer starred as a
sleazy Hollywood director in the Polish experimental
action movie 11 Minutes.
The film chronicles the lives of a number
of Warsaw residents, including a low-level
drug runner, an elderly artist, a hot-dog
vendor, a skyscraper window washer, a student,
a team of paramedics, and an actress and her
jealous husband.
As director Richard Martin holds an "audition"
for the actress in a hotel room, the rest
of the characters go about their lives.
But for 11 minutes, their paths all intersect
in unexpected and life-changing ways.
Fortitude
2015 continued to be a busy year for the actor,
as that's when Dormer got his own starring
television role in the Amazon Original series
Fortitude, playing Sheriff Dan Anderssen,
the man charged with protecting the residents
of an isolated town.
The town of Fortitude is historically
peaceful.
But that all changes when a local scientist
is found brutally murdered — the first violent
crime in the town's history.
"This would not stop me, nevermind a bear."
Unbeknownst to Anderssen, one of the town's
residents has placed a call resulting in the
arrival of London Police Inspector Eugene
Morton, who comes to Fortitude to "help" with
the investigation.
The show has run for two seasons thus far,
with fellow Game of Thrones alumni Michelle
Fairley joining the cast in season two.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!